there are so many new Beauty releases
happening all the time so we gathered
some of the most typed products to test
for ourselves elf has been killing it
with its new releases lately and we need
to talk about this new power grip primer
because it's excellent immediately I
compared it to my milk Hydro grip primer
they are virtually identical in terms of
texture and how they apply except this
elf one is obviously cheaper just like
the hydro grip primer it creates a
really nice tacky base for foundation
that's meant to make your makeup last
longer my Foundation Blended out really
nicely on top of this it wasn't pilling
or doing anything out of the ordinary I
took some pictures about five to six
hours after I applied and I do think my
makeup lasted really well even my blush
which is literally always the first
thing to disappear on my face elf also
released this powder foundation in its
camo line I'll be honest powder
foundations are just not my thing I
don't like how they look on my skin but
the camel line has had nothing but hits
so I had to try this the powder is so
soft and it Blends out very easily it
definitely evened out my skin tone and
blurred some of those areas I have of
discoloration however it just looks
powdery I don't think it gives my skin
the most flattering texture I forgot to
set it with some spray to see if that
helps at all but I don't see myself
liking this even with setting spray to
melt it in a bit this is not for me I
love trying new mascaras this is the
makeup Revolution 5D lash pow mascara
it's supposed to make it look like
you're wearing falsies the size of this
brush is astronomical oh my God but I
love a big natural bristle mascara brush
right away I could tell that this
mascara was doing a really nice job of
thickening my lashes and the more I
built it up it gave my lashes this nice
little curl I naturally have straight
lashes and I hate curling them so I was
really happy with the effect this
mascara gave them also I love how you
push the cap down to open it it's really
satisfying to me the Fenty Beauty
kilowatt freestyle highlighter is
definitely not new but Madison Beer said
she uses this one in ginger binge slash
Moscow Mule as a blush and everyone
bought it including me Fenty
highlighters are more glittery than
[ __ ] so I was a little nervous about
how how this was going to look on me and
the texture on my cheeks it was
definitely more metallic looking because
it's a highlighter and not a blush but I
actually did not hate this at all I did
have to go over it with my sponge to
take away some of that Glitter but the
color and the glow it brought to my
cheeks was super pretty I don't think I
don't think you need this specific
product for this kind of effect but if
you're gonna try it I recommend sticking
to the side with less glitter Charlotte
Tilbury just dropped this beautiful skin
Foundation the claims on the box were so
funny to me like skin tone looks more
even by up to 210 sure this Foundation
had a way thicker consistency than I
expected and I think because of that it
didn't really melt into my skin the way
I wanted it to the coverage leaned more
on the lighter side so I went back into
certain areas and added some more it's
definitely buildable but I'm not
obsessed with how my skin is looking I
don't think it looks cakey it just looks
like I'm wearing foundation and it's not
as Skin like as the name would have you
think do I think my skin tone looks more
even by up to 210 I can't really say but
this is just okay to me I saw a tick
tock that said this Sigma renew lip oil
is a possible dupe for the 35 Dior lip
oil so I had to compare the two because
I'm obsessed with the Dior lip oil It
Feels So nourishing on the lips and it
has that big doe foot applicator that
feels so I could literally apply this
all day the sigma lip oil looks so much
like it look at these applicators
they're almost identical the sigma one
is hydrating and shiny and it gives you
that moisturizing non-sticky feeling it
feels so much like the Dior one the only
discernible difference I found between
the two is that the sigma one has no
scent and the dr1 does it's 22 dollars
which is still really pricey for a lip
oil and it only comes in four Shades but
I think this is a really good dupe
highly recommend
you guys have been asking me to try out
some rare Beauty on this show so I
picked up the new warm wishes effortless
bronzer stick and the always an optimist
soft radiant setting powder let's talk
about the bronzer stick first I
immediately got nervous watching it on
the back of my hand because it looked so
red but I was so shocked when I saw how
easily it Blended in I don't know why I
applied this like it was a contour stick
but it worked out for me the texture of
this is something special it's super
smooth and soft and velvety and it
doesn't blend into nothing you still see
that color you still get the warmth of a
bronzer it looked way less red when I
applied it to my face so I was actually
really happy with this now the setting
powder I'll admit right now I made a
mistake getting the medium shade I
should have gone for light medium but I
expected this to be way more sheer than
it actually was I normally use a
translucent powder so using the setting
powder with color was new for me
applying it with my sponge was an
immediate no it made my skin look so
patchy and weird my powder brush was
definitely the way to go the powder was
super finely milled and it gives your
skin that soft blur that looks really
pretty it made my skin look a lot
smoother on the side where I used my
brush it's still a little patchy in
terms of color but that's obviously my
fault because this is not my color I
definitely need to try this again in my
appropriate shade and finally let's talk
about the new NYX Thicket stick it brow
gel it's described as a thickening brow
mascara if you look really closely you
can see those little fibers that are
supposed to make your brows look fuller
and fluffier I actually bought this for
myself and used it once and thought it
was just okay but I had no idea you were
supposed to layer it so I did that this
time around and my brows came out so
much better I'm obsessed with how this
white brow looks the left one not so
much but that's always my problem bro I
kind of wish this had a smaller brush
because I kept accidentally spreading
the product outside of my brows but I do
like the natural full effect that you
get with this I haven't tried a hard
candy product since I was a kid but this
glitter palette blew up on Tick Tock
this is the glitterati glitter eye
palette in Glitz and she here the
glitter is not loose it does have some
sort of sticky base that holds it
together and makes it really easy to
glide on I was honestly Blown Away by
how pigmented these Glitters are I used
my fingers to apply it to my eyes these
top two shades do that thing where
depending on what angle your face is at
the glitter disappears and reappears
it's so magical and pretty I will say
that I did get glitter Fallout so I'd
recommend using another glitter base to
make sure that doesn't happen but I had
fun playing around with this palette if
you're someone who's into glitter I
highly recommend it Fenty Beauty just
came out with the icon semi matte
refillable lipstick so the case and the
actual lipstick are sold separately and
then you assemble them together I'm not
gonna lie it took me a minute to figure
out but I did eventually I got the shade
the MVP which is another Universal red
from Fenty that's supposed to look good
on every skin tone the shape of the
lipstick was actually inspired by
Rihanna's iconic Cupid's bow and I
actually found it really easy to sort of
map out my lip line with it since I
didn't apply any lip liner before the
pigment is incredible and totally full
coverage it's just a very creamy formula
that feels so smooth and hydrating on
the lips I can't even believe this is
semi matte it's definitely not transfer
proof but I was actually really
impressed by how it looked after I
kissed my hand clearly so much product
came off but the lipstick still looked
incredible it is interesting to see
regular lipstick releases in the age of
mask wearing but this formula is
excellent Nars has a new Foundation
formula the light reflecting Advanced
Skin Care Foundation Nars knows how to
do complexion products so well and it
has a huge hit with this I've actually
been using this for weeks now and I'm
completely in love with it the
foundation is so lightweight on the skin
it feels like you're not even wearing
Foundation the coverage is on the light
to medium side but I definitely think
you can build it up without it getting
cakey the Finish is so nice it makes
your skin look really fresh and dewy
without looking oily and all of my other
products layer on top of this Foundation
really well KVD Beauty released its good
apple lightweight full coverage
concealer the name had me so intrigued
because usually full coverage products
can get heavy on the skin and my under
eyes are so picky about what concealer
they like I immediately love this
applicator shape it picks up a good
amount of product and the shape makes it
easy to apply I could tell from testing
it out on the back of my hand that it
actually does feel way more lightweight
than I expected but it covers really
well I applied it everywhere I normally
apply concealer let it all sit for a
second and then started blending this
concealer Blends like a dream it just
melts into the skin without losing any
coverage I did add a little more on my
under eye area just for some extra
brightening and it layered beautifully
no problems there and then I set it all
with the powder and I think it still
looked really good while feeling super
light on the face the name did not lie
colourpop released these adorable
heart-shaped pressed powder blushes just
in time for Valentine's Day they kept
sealing out but I managed to get this
bright Coral shade called Forever Yours
these blushes look deceptively matte in
the pan but if you look at my finger
Swatch it's definitely got a pretty
Sheen which I love this blush was so
unbelievably pigmented I tapped my brush
brush off before I applied it and it
still went on this intensely but I went
back in with a clean brush to tone it
down and it looked so much better this
blush formula is really silky and pretty
plus a little goes a really long way so
I love this also I am a sucker for
anything heart-shaped Carla Cosmetics is
a totally new brand for me and I've been
dying to try its shadow potion gel
eyeshadow it's this multi-chrome gel
eyeshadow I swatched it on my hand first
and this texture isn't something I've
really tried before I just went in with
my fingers and did Gentle tapping
motions it does dry quickly but not so
quickly that you don't have time to work
with it it definitely showed up as more
pinky purple on my eyes with olive green
on the outer Corners that multi-chrome
shift depends on the lighting so I think
it looked more obvious away from direct
sunlight
milk makeup recently released this rise
mascara I actually love their Kush
mascara so I was really excited to try
this and then I actually tried it this
is just so average it took me three
layers for it to give my lashes any sort
of lift and even that effect was subtle
I've tried drugstore mascaras that have
done a lot more for a lot less this is
the mini size and it was 14 bucks I will
say I did love the packaging this
material kind of feels like a pencil
grip and I love that the actual mascara
not so much
this is the kimchi Chic Beauty Teddy Kim
palette in the boyfriend color story
it's an eyeshadow and face palette I
went in with the blush and highlighter
first and I loved them they were really
buildable and went on so smoothly moving
on to the eyeshadow you do get a nice
mix of mattes shimmers and Glitters I
think all of these colors work together
really well I went in with a couple of
mattes first and they Blended great then
I played around with these shimmers and
Glitters again these applied great
they're super shiny and reflective but I
did get Fallout with the glitter so I
recommend using a primer overall I was
very happy with this palette and another
fun thing about it is that it actually
comes with stickers so you can customize
your little bear my bear definitely goes
to Euphoria high but yes I love this I
can see this being really good for
travel although maybe a little bit hard
to pack
the rose ink skin enhanced luminous
tinted Serum is one of the weirdest
products I've seen in a while it's
basically a skin tint with this serumi
base that's filled with pigment beads
that give you some coverage they say to
apply this with a brush to break up and
spread those pigment beads so that's
what I did I really went into this
thinking it was just going to look like
an oily mess on me but then I noticed
how good it was making my skin look the
coverage is light but it's just enough
that it gives this my skin naturally
looks like this with no effort kind of
look I typically hide any imperfections
on my face with a more full coverage
Foundation but this made my skin look so
smooth and dewy that I didn't feel like
I needed more but this product really
shocked me not only in how good it
looked but also and how good it made me
feel this is the elf cookies and dreams
lip gloss in cookie dreams and yes it is
a black lip gloss with a bunch of pretty
blue and silver glitter throughout I
tried this out on my bare lips first and
I didn't love it because you can see in
the area is where the gloss tends to
pull a bit more it has this very obvious
bluish black tint that looked a little
odd on me but then I applied this over
my favorite lip liner and I immediately
understood why people liked this so much
oh my God it looked incredible over lip
liner it kind of gave the liner a deeper
look that just worked so well and the
formula of the gloss itself is actually
really nice for the four dollar price
point I'm definitely hanging on to this
to layer over other lip products I was
so excited to try this Huda Beauty Easy
Bake loose baking and setting powder in
cherry blossom I had to get this baby
version because the full size was
completely sold out it's a baby pink
setting powder that's supposed to really
brighten up the under eyes I just
applied my concealer like normal and
went in with a little puff that comes
with it this puff is nice but the shape
was really annoying to use so I did use
a brush to get into the hard to reach
spots this powder does have a very
strong floral scent that was actually
giving me a headache so I had to remove
it after a few minutes it recommends
that you leave it on for five but I
couldn't take it any anymore I'm sorry I
did see a slight brightening effect but
it wasn't blowing me away I could still
see my dark circles peeking through a
bit I do however think that this is a
nice powder formula it's really
smoothing and super finely milled but
they need to get rid of the scent
Maybelline just dropped its Super Stay
vinyl ink long wear no budge liquid lip
color this is a long wearing lipstick
that's meant to say shiny which really
got my attention you have to shake it
for five seconds then apply when I first
started applying I got nervous because
it looked really patchy but I got full
coverage when I added another layer and
it surprisingly felt lightweight on the
lips I kissed my hand to check for
transfer and there definitely was some I
did a test wearing my mask and saw some
transfer there too and then I took a sip
of my drink and saw minimal transfer
there as well even though I was getting
a little transfer and most of the shine
was gone the lipstick itself still
looked super bright and it didn't move
anywhere so I was happy with that this
is the Dior backstage flash perfector
concealer I think the main thing that's
special about this is that it has a
brush applicator instead of a doe foot
applicator so that's supposed to be
easier to blend in I still had to use my
sponge for blending but I did like how
easy application was with the brush
although I wouldn't say it was any
easier than a regular doe foot
applicator the formula itself is really
nice the coverage is more on the medium
side but it covered enough I like this
concealer but I wouldn't tell you to go
run and get it it's just a nice
concealer with a high-end name on it the
beauty blender power pocket puff is
basically a double-sided velor puff so
the pink side is for powder application
and the tan side is for blending the
powder and makeup it does pick up a lot
of product I tried to tap off as much as
I could but it still deposited a lot of
powder it is described as a tool you can
use for baking the under eye area so
maybe that's why the shape does make it
easy to use and I liked how it has this
little strap on it that can be used on
either side after leaving the powder on
for a bit I used the tan side to blend
it in and it wasn't getting rid of all
the powder so I did use a brush to dust
off the excess I I noticed that my under
eye area looked really smooth smoother
than when I set the area with my normal
sponge the lines under my eyes weren't
as defined this is the new Mac Max stack
mascara and it's supposed to be super
volumizing which I love what I don't
love is a plastic mascara brush which
this has but I was still excited to try
this when I first started applying I
immediately hated the feeling of the
brush on my eye it's a little too spiky
for someone like me with pretty
sensitive eyes I noticed an instant lift
and volume with my lashes which are
naturally pretty straight I did another
coat and loved how this made my lashes
look they look long and full without
looking clumpy I don't know if I can
justify 28 dollars for mascara but this
one is so good I might have to splurge
on it every now and then we have two new
face products from one size Beauty the
cheek Clapper 3D blush Trio palette and
the made for shade bronze and sculpt
Trio let's get into the skull palette
first I used a mix of the bottom two
shades and they brought some much needed
warmth to my face they blend really
nicely and smoothly these are nice
bronzers but I think the real star of
the show here is the blush palette like
if I had to pick one of these two
palettes to splurge on it would
definitely be this one these are three
different formulas a flex cream a full
impact matte and a hyper Sheen I went in
with a very light hand because these are
really pigmented and they just look
really beautiful and smooth on the skin
the color can be built up or toned down
as much as you want which I think is my
favorite thing about this palette there
are just so many different ways you can
use it and all the formulas work so
nicely together rare Beauty just
released the positive light tinted
moisturizer with SPF 20 I was so happy
that this had SPF in it the formula felt
thicker and looked more full coverage
than I expected also this was a shade or
two too light for me so ignore that it
does sheer out as you apply it so it
looks less like a foundation and more
like a tinted moisturizer I applied the
rest of my powder makeup on top and
honestly wasn't loving how it looked I
felt like it kept building up in the dry
patches around my nose and just looked a
little too textured but then I redid my
makeup with all cream products on top of
this tinted moisturizer and it looked so
much better just super dewy and fresh so
I much prefer using it with cream
products this is the Nyx Wonder stick
Cream Blush contour and it's literally a
blush stick that you use to Contour your
face there's a lighter shade that's
meant to be used as a blush and a Deeper
Shade that you Contour with I have never
contoured with blush so I was really
intrigued by this I applied the darker
shade wherever I would normally contour
and the lighter shade above it and then
blended it out this isn't the easiest
formula to blend but I eventually got it
looking pretty good I didn't hate the
blush Contour look I just think this
blush formula isn't great and I've
definitely tried better at the drugstore
I haven't experimented much with
correctors but I saw Tick Tock
recommending this one the benefit boing
bright on brightening under eye
concealer it has this peachy color to
counteract the darkness underneath the
eyes I tested it out before applying
makeup and I could see a difference
already so then I applied a small amount
Blended that then applied concealer on
top and I think it did make a difference
my under eyes looked brighter than usual
I definitely noticed less Darkness than
when I just used concealer and the
product didn't do anything weird to the
concealer I applied on top it didn't
make it patchy or a bunch up so I'm
actually really into this I realized
later you're just supposed to wear this
on its own which I clearly did not do
but I was still happy with the results
Charlotte Tilbury came out with a new
pillow talk collection inspired by its
popular lipstick in pillow talk so I
picked up a few of the products I
already love the beauty light one so I
knew that I would love this Pillow Talk
shade it's super glowy and makes the
skin look so beautiful the multi-glow
highlighter was a new product for me the
packaging is so pretty I didn't even
want to touch it but I did it has this
almost soft blurring effect that looks
really nice and it's not glittery at all
just like a soft glove the product I was
most excited to try was actually the
mascara in the shade dream pop it's
described as a berry Brown shade I don't
think I've ever tried a colored mascara
before but I applied it like I normally
would and I actually love the color the
formula isn't my favorite and neither is
the brush but I think the color was
actually flattering on my eyes it's
supposed to bring out the Amber in brown
eyes I don't know if that's what's
happening but it did make my eyes look
really sparkly which I love I saw that
Flower Beauty had this Spotlight liquid
highlighter that looked a lot like the
Charlotte Tilbury light wand in the
Pillow Talk shade so I really wanted to
compare the two to see if it was a dupe
the shades aren't exactly the same but
they're super close both are so easy to
blend out and look more natural and dewy
on the skin than a powder highlight does
I think the Charlotte Tilbury one is a
bit more reflective than the Flower
Beauty one but the effect is definitely
similar The Flower Beauty one looks just
as beautiful on the skin and it's almost
30 dollars cheaper so I highly recommend
this if you haven't gotten a chance to
try the light ones I'm an East Coast
girl so I was so excited when I saw that
elf collabed with Duncan this was such a
fun cute idea this huge donut sponge was
so ridiculous I had to try it out it's
big even before wedding and it was
pretty hard at first but it doubled in
size once I wet it and it became a lot
softer and squishier I'm not gonna lie
applying foundation with this is kind of
great because it's so big it literally
applies foundation in five seconds I
decided to use it to apply all my other
makeup and the size does get more
difficult to work with the more precise
you're trying to be you can see that I
was accidentally spreading my blush up
way too high but I think overall the
makeup came out looking good obviously
this is more like a novelty than a super
useful makeup tool but it comes in handy
if you want to apply makeup quickly I
also ordered the glaze for days lip
gloss set because I cannot resist an
orange gloss let alone an orange gloss
that smells like glazed donuts this is a
really nice gloss the color is pretty
sheer but for the price point I think
this formula is super glossy and
comfortable on the lips Donnie Davey the
head makeup artist of euphoria just came
out with her own makeup line Half Magic
and I bought a bunch of products to test
out first up we have these Chrome
addiction matte eye paints they have a
lot of pigment and we're really easy to
layer and blend they don't dry down too
fast and you can use them as eyeliner
which is what I did they have this
reusable Wing guide which was okay I
feel like it was a little too flimsy so
I didn't get that great of a wing with
this this glitter pill was so pretty and
the applicator made it so easy to use
plus you don't have to use a glitter
base it just dries down and stays put
the light wrap glow powders definitely
do give you a nice glow and you can use
them anywhere on the face like I put
this purple one on my eyes and it looked
so cool of course I also had to get
these iridescent face gems which are
self-adhering so you don't need any glue
for the first use you will need glue if
you reuse them these are so easy to
apply and add such a cute Sparkle the
last product I got was The Magic brownie
lip trick kit it has a darker and
lighter lip liner so you can customize
the lipstick the lip liner is very
smooth and creamy and this lipstick is
super comfortable on the lips this brand
is a whole really inspires you to play
with your makeup which I love and I
really liked the products that I tried
I'm excited to see what they come out
with next danessa myrick's Beauty just
released this skin blurring balm powder
I got the universal shade which is
translucent and I also got the shade
four so you can use this as a primer
concealer and Contour a foundation or it
can be used to set your foundation I
first tried the universal one as a
primer under my go-to Foundation the
texture is kind of strange it Blends in
easily like a bomb wood but it dries
down to like a soft matte powder finish
it really does blur a lot of
imperfections my Foundation went over
this so smoothly and it did make it
slightly more matte than it usually
looks but I didn't mind then I tried the
tinted shade just as a foundation it did
take me a while to blend out but once I
did I really liked the finish this is
actually more full coverage than I was
expecting I feel like it covered a lot I
did end up wearing this for the entire
day and I noticed that I was much less
oily at the end of the day than usual it
does have a bit of a learning curve but
once you figure out how to make this
work for your skin it's a really cool
product
I don't know why it's taken me this long
to try the about face matte fluid eye
paints but I'm finally doing it these
are liquid eye colors that come in full
coverage mats or sheer Shades don't be
scared by that orange Swatch that one is
a sheer shade the pigment in these is
incredible they're super easy to apply
and to blend out you can build up the
color if you want and it still feels
lightweight plus I'm in love with this
packaging these are amazing and I need
more colors the espresso glassy blush is
one of those pH reactive products it
goes from clear to a pink tint on the
skin I first tried it over my foundation
and it started to break down the product
I already had on it was pilling so much
so we were off to a bad start I tried it
out on my bare skin and it worked a lot
better it's cute and a fun idea but I'm
not blown away by this I would rather
just get a blush that works on skin and
over makeup this is the B dellium large
rounded double Dome blender and it looks
like a little mouth it's big basically
like two brushes in one it's supposed to
blend in product really fast and give
you an airbrushed finish you can use it
with any liquid cream or powder products
so I decided I would do a full face with
just this brush I was immediately Blown
Away by how quickly and seamlessly this
Blended in the product plus this was
like the softest brush I've ever felt
you're supposed to do these back and
forth motions and I thought it would
look so streaky but it just looked
really smooth and well Blended because
of the size it is a little difficult to
use for the more precise products like
concealer but they do sell smaller sizes
of this brush I loved it this is the say
Hydro beam brightening and hydrating
under eye concealer it has a radiant
finish which had me a little worried I
don't really think radiant when I'm
picking out a concealer the coverage is
light a little too light for my taste
I'm a medium to full coverage girl when
it comes to concealer but the Finish is
pretty and skin like it also looked good
when I set it with powder but I
absolutely hate the applicator on this
this in my opinion it's too short it is
so stiff and it doesn't do a great job
of picking up and spreading the product
around other than that this is a very
nice everyday concealer these are the
tarte maracuja juicy lip plumps and
they're supposed to give you a tingle
free Plumping they actually are so juicy
look at how shiny that is my first
reaction to these was that they are
incredibly fragile like you want to be
careful with how much pressure you're
using because it will break so I didn't
love that but these feel so good on the
lips like I could not stop rubbing them
together it's so comfortable and
hydrating the Plumping was actually
tingle free for me it just felt minty
like I rubbed toothpaste on my lips the
Plumping effect is subtle but I still
really liked these
I did it I bought the Jones Road Beauty
what the foundation this has caused all
kinds of controversy and discourse so I
apologize for also putting in my two
cents this is what it looks like it's
very oily and thick it has a scent I
actually don't mind it's like a soft Spa
like smell I applied a pretty small
amount for me with my fingers and then
went over that with my sponge and I did
not hate how this looked it's very skin
like it felt like I wasn't even wearing
Foundation I will say it tends to gather
in certain areas so I might have to go
in with even less product my other
products layered on top of this fine but
I feel like I like this more as an
everyday skin tint rather than a
foundation base for my makeup like I
would reach for this when I'm running
errands on a Sunday morning but not when
I'm going to the club I've been obsessed
with lip oils so I immediately snatched
up this Fenty Beauty cherry tree
conditioning and strengthening lip oil I
have to start off by saying this is the
most amazing smelling lip product it
smells like Cherry candies we got this
giant doe foot applicator I love I did
not want to stop applying this it felt
so nice this formula makes your lips
feel so hydrated and soft and cushiony
if that makes any sense it's also so
glossy the color is so sheer it doesn't
really look like much on my lips but I
love this and it's definitely going in
my bag I also got the Fenty Beauty
popsicle hydrating lip stain this also
feels so good on the lips every lip
stain I've tried has been more drying
not hydrating so I am really into this
formula it's very pigmented so I was
careful when I was applying to make sure
I didn't get the stain anywhere outside
of my lips after leaving it on for a few
minutes I wiped it off with a paper
towel and there was definitely a pretty
stain left behind that was a hundred
percent transfer proof I can see myself
wearing this a lot this summer if you
can believe it I have never tried a
house Labs product before they recently
rebranded and I picked up a couple of
products first up this house Labs high
power pigment paint you can use this
anywhere on the face the pigment in
these actually took me by surprise like
I was not expecting them to be so full
coverage you need like the tiniest
amount of these it Blended out pretty
easily on my eyes and it doesn't dry too
quickly so you have some time to work I
am so into these I also picked up the
PHD hybrid lip oil this applicator is
much smaller than the Fenty one which
made me sad but the actual formula is
really smooth and comfortable on the
lips it's more of a thinner formula than
other lip oils I've tried but I really
loved how this looked and felt this also
has no scent which I prefer over a bad
scent these were great products and I
need to try more
Uma Beauty just released this trip and
smooth powder and what's so cool about
it is how the powder dispenses you twist
it and it releases the perfect amount of
powder which I love because my powders
get so messy the powder itself is so
finely milled and silky smooth smooth it
applied really nicely and smoothed out
my under eyes a bit so I really liked it
I've been on the hunt for a good talc
free powder and I think this is it the
only thing I wish they had was a
translucent option but this is so good I
tried two products for makeup Revolution
let's start with this blush bomb cream
blusher this straight up looks and feels
like a lip gloss it was very confusing
it's definitely more of an oily blush
formula than I'm used to First
application wasn't great it's pretty
sheer but it does build up I don't think
I like this though I think it just feels
like lip gloss on my cheeks I also tried
the superfix misting spray I know I just
complained about the blush looking like
a lip gloss but I love that this looks
like a Hairspray the Mist is nice but I
wish it was a continuous Mist I applied
this underneath my makeup and then on
top when I was finished that's how I
like to use a setting spray it melted
the makeup in nicely but I typically
like a more dewy finish and this is
pretty matte I wore this makeup for
eight hours and I think I looked okay at
the end of the day I feel like I could
still see my blush which is usually the
first thing to disappear this isn't my
favorite setting spray but I do think
it's a good cheaper option Pat McGrath
released a new shade of her skin fetish
highlighter and bomb Duo this has a bomb
on one side and this really beautiful
highlighter on the other this shade
extreme cyber Orchid is so interesting
it shifts from a blue to a lilac and
totally disappears at certain angles
this formula is definitely balmy but not
in an oily way I got so nervous when I
first applied it because this was not
blending in at all but it Blended in
really nicely when I used my fingers I
think for 58 bucks I would rather get a
more wearable everyday shade but this
formula is really nice this is the
Maybelline Tattoo Studio brow lift stick
which is supposed to give you a brow
lift or brow lamination effect at home
it has a cool little brush on one side
and then this colored wax on the other
so you brush your brows up first apply
the wax to fill in and then use the
brush to lift the brow hairs this is a
cool idea idea and I did like how it
made my brows look but it did take a bit
of work I think if this brush had firmer
bristles it would be easier to get that
brow lift effect I also just don't think
this wax is waxy enough to hold my brows
up all day so this was just okay I'm a
big fan of the made by Mitchell blurches
I tried a purple blush from them before
and I loved it and they just came out
with a lavender shade so I had to try it
applying it on top of my makeup was a
mistake because it's a pastel it was
basically like I applied a white blush
over my bronzer plus it actually made my
Foundation patchy which is an issue that
I've never had with this formula I think
I might have just over Blended trying it
out on bare skin wasn't any better it
just leaves this very gray looking cast
I looked like the Corpse Bride I think
I'm better off using this as an eyeliner
and eyeshadow base Clinique has finally
come out with the lip gloss version of
its iconic black honey lipstick this
color is definitely identical to the
lipstick version just glossy here's what
they look like side by side I liked it a
little more once I dab some off this
color is just really flattering I have
to say though this gloss formula is not
my favorite I think they were going for
a cushiony feel but it's just kind of
sticky and thick looks great but it
doesn't feel so great elf released this
Halo glow liquid filter and the world
stopped could this actually be a dupe
for the Charlotte Tilbury Flawless
filter let's see on this side of my face
I applied Flawless filter it's gorgeous
it's glowy it's perfect now on this side
I applied the elf Halo glow look at them
side by side they are almost identical I
would say that the elf one has a hint
more coverage but it still gives that
same your skin but better effect and the
Charlotte Tilbury one is slightly more
glowy slightly I say save yourself the
extra 30 bucks and get the elf one side
note look at the size of the stove foot
it's huge you guys know I adore rare
Beauty I was so excited when they
dropped these kind words matte lipsticks
and lip liners I had to get the color
gifted because Selena said that that was
her favorite the lip liner is super
smooth even though it's matte it doesn't
drag or pull on the lips plus it's a
Twist up which I love the lipstick is so
creamy and pigmented you could probably
put this on in one swipe it's definitely
one of the most comfortable matte
lipsticks I've ever tried scranny beauty
is a brand I found on Tick Tock I kept
seeing videos of its spicy sauce lip
plumper and I really wanted to test it
out since I haven't had much luck with
lip plumpers I applied it to half my
lips so we could see if it actually does
anything so you apply it slightly above
your lip line and it starts to feel a
little spicy then it starts to feel
tingly and spicy and then at the three
minute Mark you also start to feel a
warming sensation I love lip plumpers so
I don't mind the roller coaster this
takes you on it feels kind of good to me
I definitely noticed Plumping especially
with my top lip I really like this lip
plumper and I also like that it's clear
so you can wear it on top of anything
Eco Styler is the brand of gel I use all
the time and I never ever knew it had
this unicorn glitter gel it's a
translucent pink color with blue
iridescent Sparkles it's so pretty
running this through my hair I feel like
you don't really get the glittery effect
it just kind of tinted my hair this
bluish color which is cool just not what
I thought it was gonna look like I
definitely saw the glitter and color
better when I applied it to brushed back
straight hair I think this is cute for a
little glitter moment every once in a
while and it actually washed out of my
hair easily I don't know if you guys
know this but I'm a nail polish freak so
when I saw it do by Jin soon going viral
I bought it immediately this is a milky
white polish it's very sheer and soft my
nails are super stained right now so I
was worried about how it was looking
after the first coat but when I went in
with that second coat it looked really
pretty and my nails looked so much
better it was a little streaky in the
first coat but the second one on totally
smooth I do wish though that this had a
flat paddle brush instead of this brush
just to make it easier to paint I'm sure
you could find find a really good
drugstore dupe for this polish because
it is on the pricey side but I really
like it this is the new Urban Decay Vice
lip Bond glossy liquid lipstick so you
get the glossiness of a lip gloss and
the wear of a liquid lipstick this is
extremely pigmented I was really
impressed by the color but I feel like
it wasn't as shiny as I thought it would
be I let it dry down for 10 minutes and
kiss the back of my hand to see if it
transferred at all and it did but only a
little bit and the lipstick still looked
good it's actually very similar to the
Maybelline vinyl ink lip color I tried a
while ago so I would probably recommend
that one since it's cheaper and performs
the same I'm not a pot concealer kind of
person but I was really excited to try
out this REM Beauty sweetener concealer
I also got the dream Cloud blender to
test out as well I scooped some up and
just warmed it on the back of my hand
then I use my fingers to apply
everywhere I wanted to conceal the
concealer looks thicker than it feels I
was actually surprised at how
lightweight it felt when I was blending
it out the coverage with this is amazing
I was so shocked at how much it covered
up you don't need a lot at all I
definitely put too much on but I really
really like this they also included a
black and white shade in this concealer
so you can lighten your shade or deepen
it which is cool I also really like this
little sponge but it's not worth fifteen
dollars these NYX ultimate glow shots
look so pretty that I literally bought
three of them they're supposed to be
brightening and give a really glowy
effect although these are gorgeous in
the tube they're just really
inconsistent on the eyes the pigment on
some is better than others but overall I
would say the pigment isn't great with
these on their own I had to build them
up a lot to get them to look like this
they definitely work better as a Topper
over other eyeshadows I'm so torn on
these because they look so good but it
takes a lot of work to get them that way
I've been seeing these gorgeous Hollow
glosses from Queen Cosmetics all over
Tick Tock of course I had to get three
of them these glosses are just as
beautiful in person they honestly feel
fine on the lips as long as you don't
apply too much I packed on this electric
shade and it did feel a little gritty so
I recommend only doing one to two Thin
layers to avoid that but these are so
cool they look good on their own but
even better over lipstick especially
darker colors this is the new Fenty
Beauty ease droplet all over glow
enhancer it can be worn on its own to
reduce the look of pores or mix into
foundation for some added glow using
this on its own I honestly wasn't very
impressed I don't think my pores were
necessarily blurred and I felt like my
skin didn't look that glowy it kind of
just looked like I applied moisturizer I
think this worked better when mixed into
a foundation I mixed it with my
eavesdrop blurring skin tint which I
love and I noticed it gave my skin a
nice little glow this skin tint is more
on the matte side so I do like that the
glow enhancer made it more dewy however
I don't think it's such a big difference
that I can justify buying this product
it kind of just feels like an extra step
that doesn't add much item beauty is
Addison Ray's Beauty brand people Rave
about it slip oil so I figure figured
I'd test it out with a couple of other
products too so this is the lip quip
moisturizing lip oil let me start out by
saying it smells amazing kind of peachy
the color was actually a little more
pigmented than I expected for a lip oil
but I thought it was so pretty the
formula is on the thicker side it feels
super nourishing and just makes your
lips look so juicy so I am really into
this this is going in my bag next I
tried the Boost juice dual ended lash
primer and colored mascara so you can
use this as a lash primer or colored
mascara the Lilac side is for volume and
the blue side is for lengthening I have
to admit I much prefer the blue side as
just a colored mascara I feel like once
I applied regular mascara on top of it
my lashes just kind of lumped together
the Lilac side barely showed up on my
lashes but it worked much better as a
lash primer I also tried the blush and
like Cream Blush it's supposed to be a
cream to powder formula but it just kind
of feels like a powder I used my sponge
to apply it at first but it just kind of
looked a little splotch G it worked much
better with a brush you can also apply
it to the lips and it was honestly cute
it's buildable which I like but I don't
feel like this is anything special
colourpop drops new stuff like every
other day but these Graphics ink liners
caught my eye I really like this tip
it's super sharp and flexible I am
horrible at doing any kind of liner
situation so I was really glad that this
tip kind of did the work for me however
the color payoff on these is not great I
found myself layering up the product for
full color payoff and with this formula
the more you layer the more textured it
looks it sucks because these are colors
that I don't really see a lot of in
eyeliner but this formula is just not my
favorite It Cosmetics just dropped
Another Love is the foundation brush I
think it drops one of these a year I
have one from a previous year that I
really love but they're actually not the
same this new one is less dense and more
flexible than my old one and I also feel
like the bristles on this new one are
longer I used it to apply my foundation
in and I was really happy with how fast
it Blended everything in without looking
streaky it also worked great with my
concealer I didn't lose any coverage
with this brush because it didn't absorb
the product I think I actually like this
new one better than my old one I tried a
couple of products from jcat beauty
let's talk about this blush first this
color is so pretty it's like an orangey
pink with a bunch of gold Shimmer in it
so you get this very buildable color
with some added glow I can definitely
see this color working for so many
different skin tones the mood flick
Hollow Sparkle lip balm is one of those
color changing lip products I honestly
thought these would be more glittery but
I think it just looked metallic on me
they do actually feel pretty
moisturizing on the lips I was really
surprised at how much these stain when I
was trying to take it off my lips were
bright pink I don't know if I'd ever use
these again but they're cute I haven't
reviewed a Too Faced product in forever
but it just released this Born This Way
ethereal light smoothing concealer and I
heard really good things about it it's
supposed to be super hydrating and
smoothing I did not like the applicator
on this not because of the shape but
because it doesn't pick a product that
well this formula is actually really
nice even after blending it out and
setting it with powder you can still see
that luminosity in the concealer I don't
know if it did much smoothing but I like
the coverage it gave me and how easy it
was to work with this is the Dior Rouge
Dior forever transfer proof lipstick not
a liquid lipstick a regular lipstick so
you apply this like any other lipstick
wait three minutes for the color to set
and you should be left with a long
wearing transfer proof lip I think this
particular shade was a bit patchy but I
evened it out as much as I could I could
not believe how well this worked I was
expecting a lot of transfer because this
is a regular lipstick but the transfer
was pretty minimal it also didn't feel
too drying on the lips I think this
formula is really cool and I want to try
out some other Shades I finally got my
hands on the house Labs Atomic Shake lip
lacquer this is another one of those
transfer proof glossy lipsticks this is
definitely like the hot new lip formula
so you shake the product well then apply
it the pigment in this really shocked me
it was so vibrant it almost looked neon
this went on so smooth I didn't need
more than one layer for full coverage
and it was so glossy I had to wait 15
seconds for what they called a shine
shield to form then I kissed the back of
my hand to see if I got any transfer and
nothing I've tried three lipsticks with
this kind of formula and so far this is
the best one this is the model ones
color cube in bonfire amore it's a solid
gel cream palette it comes with nine gel
polishes and you can get them in
different color stories and finishes it
also comes with this little brush I've
used a solid gel cream before but I
forgot how thick it actually is so it
did take me some time to apply it in
even layers I did have to do two coats
for full coverage on some colors I think
a product like this can be super
convenient especially if you do nail art
or just don't have the space to keep a
bunch of gel polishes around it it
doesn't come with a base or top coat but
I still really like this I tested out a
ton of products from Jason Wu Beauty
this is a new brand for me so let's
start with what I didn't like this Frida
brow was too light for me which is my
fault but the formula on this is weird
it feels like an oily cream that never
dries down so I doubt it'll keep my
brows in place these stay in line lip
liners weren't great they were also too
light for me so I ended up using my own
lip liner to deepen it these are smooth
but a little too creamy they don't feel
like they're gonna last very long on the
lips at all I also didn't like the woo
Prime eye the formula is so tacky and
thick it made my eyeshadow look patchy
in certain areas now on to the stuff I
loved this Flora four palette was
surprisingly pigmented and easy to blend
I feel like the primer is what got in
the way of showing you its full
potential but I still really liked it
this blush Trio is so gorgeous and
Blended out really nicely I use this
ready to Shimmer cream shadow as a
highlighter and it gave me the prettiest
Golden Glow even though it's not really
meant for the face this Jewel stick was
incredible look how much it brightened
up my inner Corners the honey fluff Lip
Cream was soft and comfortable on the
lips
if you get anything from this brand get
this extra pout lip plumper oh my God
even if you don't care about the lip
Plumping aspect this is one of the best
lip gloss formulas I have ever tried
it's so cushiony and shiny and amazing
and everyone should get it the makeup
forever the professional mascara is
definitely a mascara it's nothing
amazing it has one side for lifting and
the other side for volumizing I didn't
get much of a lift but I did get a nice
amount of volume I just think there are
better mascaras out there for way less
money I am a huge fan of about face I
love so many of its products so when
these cheek freak blush bombs dropped I
snatched up three different colors I'm
just gonna say it I am so in love with
these I was nervous at first because
it's described as a blush balm which to
me sounded like it would break up my
Foundation but these Blended in so
beautifully it never moved the product
underneath even if my skin was already
powdered and the pigment on these is
unreal you can build them up however
much you you want I think these can work
for so many different skin tones they
are so so good I made the horrible
mistake of purchasing the winky Lux
Saucy gloss four piece combo lip gloss
set this was made in collaboration with
Applebee's and the glosses are inspired
by its wing sauces you guys I thought
everyone was exaggerating when they said
the smell was making them gag but no
these smell got awful and it sucks so
bad because the color story is so pretty
and I could like see this concept
working had they just not added the
sauce since or even if they did
something like lemon pepper smells like
lemon Buffalo is just a spicy lip
plumper but no they went in this
direction we all bought it and talked
about it which is probably what they
wanted so I hope you're happy winky
looks you ruined four beautiful glosses
I tried out a new Foundation from Chanel
I actually wouldn't call this a
foundation it's more like a super
hydrating light tint it's very similar
to that rosing tinted serum I tried a
while ago so it has these pigment beads
that burst and spread as you apply it
this literally feels like nothing on the
skin there is little coverage but it
evens everything out nicely and it feels
hydrating I don't think this has a
strong staying power but it's still a
pretty tint for when you don't want to
do too much Chanel also has a blush in
this formula so I tested that out too I
actually blended it out on the back of
my hand before applying and tapped it on
with a sponge it took a minute to build
up the color but I think it's supposed
to look very natural it also didn't
break up the product underneath I'm
surprised by how much I liked these they
don't do too much but it's enough to
make a difference this is the Maybelline
Shadow blocks eyeshadow palette it's a
tiny stack of eyeshadows very similar to
the Kaja Bento trios the packaging is
pretty cheap one of my Shadows fell out
but it's okay I applied these without
any primer just to see how they perform
on their own they're actually pretty
pigmented Shadows I didn't have any
trouble blending them and the Shimmer
shade was pretty but overall I think
these are just okay I like the idea of a
palette like this more than the
execution everyone has been loving these
NYX jumbo lash lashes so I had to try
them even though I am terrible with
false lashes I thought the style ego
flare would look nice on my eye shape
and I was right these lashes made me
feel like a whole new person like these
are Disney princess eyes they were
pretty easy to apply and the band was
really comfortable I think these have
totally convinced me to wear lashes more
often this is the Urban Decay 24 7 Munda
shadow in Space Cowboy this is basically
a glitter Shadow this shade in
particular has been going viral it is
super intense and reflective but you can
definitely diffuse it to be more subtle
this formula is really smooth and easy
to work with however you want to use it
so I really loved this I did get some
glitter Fallout so I'd recommend using a
primer or leaving some powder under the
eyes while you're applying if you want
something more eye-catching and elevated
than a shimmer Shadow this is perfect M
Cosmetics re-released its color drop
serum blush with a new and improved
formula and packaging the old packaging
was notoriously difficult to use it had
this dropper thing that just would not
dispense properly this new dropper is so
much better you do have to build this
blush up but it gives you a really
pretty dewy flush of color I honestly
can't see a difference between the old
formula and the new one this new one is
just easier to use I'm not super into
this kind of blush formula I prefer the
Brand's powder or cream blush over this
but it's pretty and it didn't break up
my Foundation I've been dying to test
out the new house Labs Foundation I've
heard nothing but amazing things and I
was not disappointed I went in with my
foundation brush first and this just
totally Blends into the skin seamlessly
the coverage is on the lighter side so I
added a little more and I am really
impressed by how weightless it is it has
skin care ingredients in it and it
actually feels like skin care it feels
like you have absolutely nothing on your
face all of my other products Blended on
top of this beautifully so this
Foundation is a 10 of 10 for me I also
got the bio blurring loose setting
powder and I love this too it definitely
does blur the skin and sets your makeup
without making it look dry or cakey it's
so soft and finely milled and it's also
talc free which is great I tried a
couple lip products from Fenty Beauty
the gloss bomb heat Universal lip
luminizer and plumper in hot chocolate
Heat and the gloss bomb ice cooling lip
luminizer in cold-hearted let's talk
about this new gloss bomb ice first it
looks like a pale blue color but it goes
on totally clear it has a really nice
minty scent you get that cooling effect
instantly and I like it it also feels
great on the lips like the other Fenty
glosses just super hydrating and shiny
the gloss bomb heat is not a new formula
but people have been loving the hot
chocolate heat shade it's like a brown
with a hint of rosiness to it because
it's on the more sheer side this color
looks incredible on so many different
skin tones and it actually does plump
the lips really nicely it's not an
uncomfortable Plumping effect at all a
few of you asked if I could review Moon
cap polishes so I have a few to talk
about this first one is called
Illusionist and it's a magnetic
multi-chrome I feel like mooncat always
has these really interesting colors like
this that I don't see very often the
magnetic effect on this one is so cool I
couldn't stop staring at my nails this
next shade is called cyclone and it's a
blue jelly flaky polish the way these
iridescent flakes look in this jelly
really give you this ocean Vibe so I
loved this one too the last polish I
tried was emo for life which is just a
plain black creme polish I honestly feel
like this one impressed me the most
because it was literally Pitch Black in
one coat the pigment on it is incredible
and the formula is so smooth the prices
do vary depending on the formula but
overall the quality of the Polish is
really good and I also love the brush
and handle on these bottles they make it
super easy to paint my nails this is the
Charlotte Tilbury take it all off it's a
bi-phase makeup remover and I had to
Google what that meant because I had no
idea it basically means you get an oil
and water in one and you have to shake
the product to combine it it
specifically says this is for eyes
lashes and lips you have to shake it
apply it to a cotton pad and soak the
area for a few seconds for an easy
removal this honestly worked really well
and I tried it on waterproof mascara
which always takes me forever to remove
I also have very sensitive eyes and this
didn't irritate them at all I liked this
but I think it's a little too pricey for
a makeup remover you're only supposed to
use on your eyes and lips say just
dropped these lip lures they're matte
lipsticks that you can build up to be
super full coverage or dab on for a soft
blurred lip I use the shade modern first
and just stabbed it on with my finger it
gave this really pretty soft wash of
color this other one in the shade
classic really shocked me because it's
so smooth and pigmented I was laughing
because I definitely went too far over
my lip line but we move I would
recommend a lip liner with these because
the formula isn't as matte as you'd
expect and it does move around a little
overall I think these are nice and feel
good on the lips this is the kimchi Chic
Beauty Pearl gone wild pressed Shimmer
highlighter this highlighter is so
stunning in the pan it's like this
iridescent pearl color that shifts to
Blue there's a lot of glitter in this
which can look chunky or make your skin
look textured but this actually went on
beautifully the glow it gives is unreal
and that blue sparkle adds a little
something special it's not going to be
for everyone especially if you hate
glitter but this formula is so pretty
and I really want more colors Patrick
Tau released these major Skin Creme
foundation and finishing powder Duos I
love the packaging on this especially
this little flap to protect the
foundation from the powder I went in
with my foundation brush first and wow
this is full coverage and a little goes
a long way I did my entire face with
just one dip into the pan I went over
that with a sponge to pick up excess
product I wouldn't say the Finish is
super skin like it definitely looks and
feels like you're wearing Foundation but
for something this full coverage it
doesn't look cakey to me it's also a
more dewy finish which I I think helps
these are the Uma Beauty Blackmagic
hypnotic impact High shine lipsticks I
am so into shiny lipstick formulas these
days formula aside though these
lipsticks are gorgeous the embossing the
glitter I could not stop staring at them
they look just as beautiful on the lips
this formula is literally a lip gloss in
lipstick form so you get the shine and
you get that moisturizing feeling the
glitter is an overspray so they don't
look glittery on the lips but I love
these this is the Merit bronze bomb and
it's supposedly the easiest bronzer ever
it's definitely the easiest bronzer I
think I've ever used it takes little to
no effort to blend this out and it
didn't break up the product I already
had on I was worried the shade I got was
too light but I think it actually turned
out okay it is buildable I just wish the
color wasn't so sheer other than that I
like this I'm seeing transfer proof
bullet lipsticks pop up a lot more
lately this one is the Nars power matte
lipstick it has a really amazing color
payoff this can definitely be a one
swipe lipstick the texture is so unique
the best way I can describe it is that
it kind of feels like the Nars soft
matte packaging on its products but on
your lips it's this soft powdery
comfortable kind of mat that felt really
nice on the lips and it is transfer
proof so I highly recommend this this is
the REM Beauty space shape brow gel what
really drew me into this product was the
applicator I've never seen one like this
before with a little doe foot on one
side and a comb on the other it was
really easy to use and I like how it
distributed the product the actual brow
gel is nice it did what it had to do and
it didn't leave my brows feeling crunchy
as much as I like the applicator though
I don't feel like the formula is
anything special KVD has reformulated
its iconic liquid lipstick so I picked
up a few Shades to try just like
everybody else I was very big into the
shade Lolita back in the day so I had to
get queen of poisons which is its new
name I'm gonna be honest I can't really
tell much of a difference between this
formula and the old one I think it maybe
feels a little more lightweight but but
it still feels like I'm wearing a
slightly drying liquid lipstick I do
really like the colors I got but this
bright orange was pretty patchy I
actually remember having the same
problem with the brighter colors in the
old formula too so that's not great I
also don't like this new packaging the
wand is so weirdly long I don't know if
you can tell but it was kind of hard to
control when I was applying I have been
dying to try these versed mood lighting
luminizing glow drops for a while people
say that this is another Flawless filter
dupe it does give a really beautiful
glow to the skin but there's not really
any coverage to it so I wouldn't call
this a dupe exactly it's like Flawless
filters more natural little sister it
has a lot of great skincare ingredients
that made my skin feel really nice and
hydrated I actually preferred the drops
under my Foundation rather than on their
own but I like these a lot this is a
face sprinkles mini palette from
designer dustco they have a lot of
different ones to choose from and you
can even make a custom palette with any
of their Glitters I was trying to show
all the colors but I couldn't lift it
all the way because one of the Glitters
was completely liquefied something weird
happened to it on its way to me but the
rest of the Glitters were totally fine
the Glitter has a vegan gel base that
dries down you can apply it on the face
hair or body I was having fun just
putting it everywhere I loved all the
colors and it was really easy to apply
I'm not really into Glitters but I think
these worked great and this is one of
the more affordable glitter gel palettes
I've seen this is the summer Friday's
sheer skin tint it's supposed to be
lightweight hydrating and very natural
on the skin I definitely think it is all
of those things the coverage is
obviously sheer but I was able to build
it up no problem it evened out my skin
nicely and it actually does feel
weightless this would be a great
everyday skin tint for me I think for
what it is and how little product you
get 42 dollars is way too much but if
you're looking for a high-end skin tint
this one is really nice I had been
getting ads for this flower nose
strawberry Rococo collection for weeks
and they definitely worked on me because
I bought three products first up I tried
the embossed blush the detail in the
embossing is so cool I didn't even want
to use it they do say that this is meant
to be a buildable blush but I think the
color payoff is a little too light it
took me forever to get the color payoff
I wanted but it did look pretty in the
end onto the eyeshadow palette the matte
formula was soft and blendable but next
time I would go in with a primer first
because it was slightly patchy in some
areas the glitter shade was incredible
it was definitely the best shade in the
entire palette but it did give me some
Fallout lastly I tried the cloud lip
cream this is one of those moosey lip
formulas that has a velvety finish this
felt really nice and comfortable on the
lips and I like the Blurred effect it
gives but I kind of wish it was the same
red as the packaging this is the Cali
Ray so blown clean primer it's one of
those dimethicony blurring primers that
makes your skin look matte I actually
like how it made my skin look without
any foundation it feels nice and velvety
and I definitely saw some blurring when
I applied my Foundation I realized I
applied too much of the primer so my
skin actually looked kind of textured
and the product peeled up a bit so the
next time I tried it I went in with less
and focused on my oily areas and I still
wasn't loving how my Foundation looked
over this I just see way more texture
with this primer than my normal primer
I'll show them side by side so maybe you
can kind of see what I mean I don't
think that this is for me Milani
released this conceal and perfect line
with liquid under eye brighteners
Contours and highlighters these kind of
feel like a drugstore version of the
Charlotte Tilbury wands first I tried
the brightener under my concealer I
didn't notice much brightening at first
but then I applied it with my fingertips
and got some better coverage next I
tried the liquid Contour this color does
lean a little bit red which I don't love
but it Blended out really beautifully
and added a nice warmth to my face I
applied the highlighter next and I loved
this again it Blends out really nicely
and it doesn't add any texture to my
skin it just gave a really pretty glow
even though I don't see myself using the
brightener I am a fan of these and I
hope they expand the shade range these
are the kaleidos Epiphany glow Melton
eyeliners they're all multi-chrome so
they have these really cool color shifts
Melton was the perfect description for
these because they really do glide on so
easily I've never had such a smooth
eyeliner application because they always
skip or they're too dry these are so
easy to apply I thought that the tip
would be too blunt to create a wing but
I was actually able to do it without any
issue these are really beautiful and I
highly recommend them I hope they expand
the line to include more everyday matte
Shades this is the got to be glued for
brows and edges for a long time people
have been using got to be hair gel as
brow gel so they came out with this
product that's actually meant for brows
I actually like how this made my brows
look it gives kind of a laminated brow
effect nice and feathery but the gel
itself left a weird residue behind and
it took forever to dry down once it did
dry the Brows pretty much stayed in
place but I've definitely tried better
brow gels this is one of the strangest
new products I've seen in a long time
this is a hip dot icon baked eye pigment
Shadow I got the Share Bear one these
are essentially 3D figures made of baked
eyeshadow they kind of feel like makeup
Funko Pops like more something you
collect rather than use but I used it
the formula was actually pretty dry it
took me a while to pick up any product
on my brush I definitely got a better
application and color payoff with my
finger but still the formula was dry and
I was tugging at my eyelid which I did
not like this feels way more like a
novelty than an actual eyeshadow Fenty
released this double cheeked up
freestyle cream blush duo so you have
this baby pink color called Malibus and
this deeper medium pink called peony
drapa I've heard that the Fenty Cream
Blush formula doesn't have the best
color payoff but these were actually
pigmented the problems for me started
with application I used a dense brush to
apply first and it did lift my
foundation so I tried my sponge and I
think I made it worse my face was not
powdered by the way on the other side I
just used my fingers and that also
lifted my Foundation but way less I do
really like these Shades so I can see
myself using this on bare skin but I am
not a fan of this for formula on top of
foundation I finally got my hands on
this 4-3 beauty honey pot lip care kit
it keeps selling out and now I know why
this kit comes with a honey lip scrub
and a lip mask this packaging is
literally so cute look at this tiny
honey dipper the scrub is like a regular
sugar scrub it made my lips feel really
soft but I wish it was a little more
coarse so I don't have to keep dipping
in for more this lip mask felt
incredible it's thick and smooth and
really hydrating and it tastes sweet
which I liked this is the Tom Ford
solanesh Lip blush lip balm it's this
transparent balm with a bunch of
platinum flecks in it it's actually one
of those color changing products so once
you apply it it turns into this deep
pink shade lip blush is a really good
way to describe it because it makes your
lips look so Rosy the actual balm
formula is really nice and hydrating but
no one on planet Earth needs a 58 lip
balm this is cute though Hollow Taco
polishes have been super popular since
they were released but I've actually
never tried them I picked up a few
different formulas to test out I really
did not like the skinny brushes these
came with but they actually sell wide
brush Replacements so I just swapped
them all out this cream shade I tried
first was so full coverage and applied
really smoothly the color was just so
rich I got this iridescent flaky topper
and I was surprised at how much I liked
it I don't really do Toppers but this
one looks so Shifty and cool on the
nails I obviously had to test out some
holographic polishes both of these also
applied really well and had amazing
color payoff I had to turn my flashlight
on so you could really see the hollow I
applied the super glossy top coat on all
of these formulas and I really loved it
I like it when my top coat has an almost
Plumping effect where it makes regular
polish kind of look like gel and this
did that while making the manicure super
shiny overall I'm really happy with all
the shades I got and I can't wait to try
more this is the Milani days of disco
Shimmer spray it's supposed to be a
holographic glitter setting spray but I
was seeing absolutely no Glitter when I
sprayed some on my hand and I shook this
really well like for a full minute I
sprayed it all over my face and it did
make my skin look extremely dewy but I
still wasn't really seeing the glitter
effect I could only see if I was looking
really really really closely the glitter
effect is definitely not as noticeable
as I thought it was going to be and the
actual setting spray formula just made
me look oily this month I tested out a
lot of products from Simi Haze Beauty
this is a new brand for me so let's
start with the stuff I liked the solar
tint blush duo comes with the cheek
pigment and a cheek gloss these both
went on really easily and the pigment is
so good surprisingly I love the cheek
gloss more even though it's not super
practical for all-day wear I didn't love
the color of this velvet blur matte lip
balm on my skin tone but the formula
itself was so good it has the comfort of
a lip balm but the pigment and blurring
effect of a matte lipstick it's creamy
and super comfortable I thought the
lunar lip gel and the super slick Mini
lip balm were just okay the lip gel was
pretty but the formula was nothing
special it's just a thin lip gloss the
mini lip balm was pretty moisturizing
and the tint is cute but it's so little
product for what you pay again nothing
special now for the products I just
didn't like I wanted to love the sun
flush all over face tint but it just
ended up being really patchy and broke
up my foundation and I tried this a few
different ways to see if I was just
applying it wrong but it still messed up
my Foundation underneath the easy lash
clean lift mascara just didn't do much
for my lashes I didn't get much lift I
got little to no volume and my lashes
weren't lengthened very much overall I
love the packaging of this brand and it
does have some standout products but I
think it's all very overpriced for how
the actual formulas perform everyone has
been raving about the summer Friday's
Lip Butter balms this set with the minis
is limited edition but they sell all of
these Shades in full size I ended up
really enjoying these the formula is on
the thicker side but but not sticky they
feel really moisturizing and I like how
they give an almost lip gloss effect I
loved all of the tinted bombs but I
think poppy was my favorite they all
give a pretty subtle wash of color and
they have this nice vanilla scent that's
not overpowering I'm obsessed with these
this is the danessa myrick's beauty
light work for Transcendence palette I'm
not gonna lie I was very intimidated by
this palette at first it has four
different formulas velvet chromes which
are color shifting powders pressed
Chrome flakes which are flaky Toppers
glass metallics which are Super
reflective powders and aqua chromes
which are water activated duochrome
pigments so there is a lot going on I
started applying over a light wash of
black eyeshadow base to make the colors
pop more but I don't even think I needed
to do that because these powders are so
pigmented I was determined to use all of
the different formulas so I added one of
the metallics in the inner corners and
put the Chrome flakes in the center the
flake were the only formula that was a
little difficult to work with only
because they're kind of hard to pick up
and apply but I think they added a
really cool texture and color shift to
the eye look I used an aqua Chrome for
some eyeliner and it's so reflective and
sparkly and it dried down quickly this
palette is extremely pricey and I did
get some slight Fallout but the quality
is definitely there and I think it's so
much more versatile than it seems the
shades in here are so transformative and
really inspire you to play with your
makeup plus it can also be used on the
face these are the L'Oreal color reach
intense volume matte lipsticks I thought
these were going to be similar to the
Nars power matte lipstick I tried a
while ago but the formula is different
the color payoff on these is so good and
they apply really smoothly this is one
of the most comfortable matte formulas
I've ever tried especially from the
drugstore what makes this lipstick
different from the Nars one is that it's
unfortunately not transfer proof to be
fair it claims to be smudge proof so
it's not the same thing regardless I
think these lipsticks are comfortable on
the lips and the colors are so rich so I
really like them
apparently Gwen Stefani has her own
Beauty brand called give and this is the
first product from it that I've ever
tried this is the double dip in two in
one lip color remover and hydrating lip
mask I wanted to test it out with my
Nars power matte lipstick since it's one
of my hardest to remove lipsticks the
formula of this lip mask feels like a
makeup removing cleansing balm if you've
never tried one they feel really oily
because of that it actually broke the
lipstick down really well it made it
super easy to remove however as a
regular lip mask it just feels way too
oily and thin to be comfortable this
just feels like one of those products
that they Market as multi-use to make it
sound more Innovative light slacker just
released its winter collection called
cocktail hour I do own a lot of their
polishes so this isn't a new brand for
me but I definitely think this is my
favorite color story they've ever done
the polishes have those wide flat
brushes I love for applying it just
makes it so much easier and faster I
tried the cream shades old money and
Audrey first and both were full coverage
into coats and the application was
really smooth then I tried the jelly
shade called lady in red because this is
a jelly it's way more sheer than a cream
so I ended up doing two thicker coats
for full color payoff the color is
slightly lighter on my nails than in the
bottle but still pretty and so shiny
next I tried to the nines which is a
metallic polish I really love this color
but this formula is probably the least
forgiving when it comes to streaks and
Bubbles my two absolute favorite Shades
from The Collection are whiskey neat and
diamonds are forever whiskey neat is
also a metallic formula but it's more of
a duochrome and diamonds are forever is
like a Milky taupe with a bunch of super
fine glitter in it I don't think these
colors separately are anything new but I
love how they all work together in this
collection and the formulas are all so
good we have yet another color changing
product to review this is the Kylie
Cosmetics transformative liquid lip tint
that was a part of her collab with the
Wizard of Oz it goes from emerald green
to Pink the smell is interesting it kind
of smells like an Appley shampoo the
formula is pretty thin I do like this
giant doe foot applicator the color is
actually a little more unique than other
color changing lip products I've tried
the pink was a bit deeper and I think
more flattering on my skin tone I would
wear this again because the stain it
leaves behind is pretty but I do wish
the formula was thicker these are the
flaky Friday Cosmetics Crystal crease
eyeliners these are handmade reusable
Crystal eyeliners that you apply with
lash glue it was a little hard for me to
get them in a comfortable spot because I
have hooded Lids you can cut these to
fit your eye shape better so I'm going
to do that next time but I think these
are so fun they look like you just did
so much work applying each individual
rhinestone circulars is one of my
favorite nail polish brands and they
just drop their holiday collection I
love that they have a spin on the
classic red and green this mix of pearly
Shades and then this more unique
duochrome sachet reminds me of red bows
and Christmas ornaments to me it leans
more pink than red but it's still
beautiful Verdigris jelly is a jelly
polish it is more sheer because it's a
jelly so I did three layers and it
looked so shiny my favorite shade in the
collection is definitely Tahitian Pearl
which is this dark duochrome that shifts
from pink to green and it has this
holographic glitter in it I did three
coats for this one too because it showed
the color shift better and I think it
made the glitter pop more this is a
really unique color and I can see myself
wearing it a lot the last three shades
are all a pearlescent sheer white with
different colored shimmers Serenity has
a green Shimmer so lay has a pinky red
Shimmer and siren has a purple Shimmer
these are all really pretty but you
definitely don't need all of them
because they're so similar this entire
collection applied really smoothly and
even though some shades had to be
layered up I was happy with how they all
turned out this is the half magic magic
flick liquid eyeliner it has this really
interesting tip that's paddle shaped so
you can draw fine lines with the edge
and then fill in with the wide side I
suck at eyeliner but this shape actually
really helps me draw the wing easily I
will will say that I think the actual
eyeliner formula is not the best the
black isn't super pigmented like I would
prefer but I really liked this tip shape
this is the KVD Dazzle long wear
eyeshadow stick it's supposed to be a
one and done type product so you don't
need primer you just swipe it on and
blend I was really surprised at how soft
this formula is it's actually a little
too soft like you have to be gentle with
it but it really does glide on easily
this is packed with glitter and Shimmer
and it just looks so pretty on the eyes
it's like a way to do glitter without
any of the mess I'm a fan I tried a
couple products from the K Beauty brand
romand this glitter palette has been
raved about so I was really excited to
play with it the shades are meant to be
on the softer more translucent side so
you can layer them over eyeshadow I just
applied some of my blush on the eyes and
then applied a few of the shades on top
there are Shimmer formulas fine Glitters
and more chunky Glitters overall I would
say the formulas are on the dry side but
they were actually pretty easy to work
with I had no problem them swiping or
padding them on and I had little to no
Glitter fall out I also tried the
glasting water tint the color and gloss
are separate layers so you get that long
lasting tint with a glossy finish these
feel so hydrating and comfortable on the
lips they're really lightweight and they
definitely do leave a stain look at my
hand after I wipe those swatches off
I've never tried a product from Jane
Iredale before but this one intrigued me
this is the hydropure tinted serum it's
a Serum with a bunch of pigment beads
inside that are meant to give you light
coverage you're supposed to mix this
with your fingers first to break up the
beads then apply with your fingers I
really don't like finger applications
for foundations but it really was the
best way to apply this product it did
not look great when I tried it with a
brush in my sponge the coverage is
definitely light I feel like it looked
like I had no makeup on at all I was
hoping it would feel moisturizing but it
felt like nothing on my skin all my
other makeup went on top of this just
fine and I really liked how my skin was
looking it's so expensive but I think
this is great for people who want a very
natural looking skin tint Charlotte
Tilbury released these hypnotizing pop
shots single Shadows the packaging on
this is so cute this is meant to be a
super glittery pigmented
multi-dimensional Shadow this was really
easy to apply I just swiped it on with
my finger and Blended out the edges I
did get a tiny bit of Fallout but I was
able to just brush it away I really love
the sparkly Shifty effect you get with
this formula you can definitely get a
similar effect with one of those
colourpop super shock Shadows but this
formula is really beautiful on the eyes
rare Beauty just released a powder
version of its super popular
highlighters I've been seeing some
conflicting statements about whether
this product looks glittery there is
definitely some super fine glitter in
this formula but I don't think it looks
glittery on the skin the glow is
obviously there and it's so pretty it's
almost wet looking I actually thought it
emphasized my texture a bit when I first
tried it when I tried it the second time
I just went in with a little less
product and it looked better I don't
think this is is as natural looking as
the liquid version but it's still a
really nice highlighter I tried a couple
new Fenty products this month the plush
puddin intensive recovery lip mask and
the glossy Posse volume 5.0 let's talk
about the lip mask first the packaging
is really cool you twist it and the
product dispenses from the top so you
don't have to dip into it the formula is
very thick which I personally love it
just feels so moisturizing and plush on
the lips it also gave this really nice
shine I wasn't expecting I did wear the
slip mask for a couple nights to see if
it helped with my dryness and I saw the
difference my lips were so much more
soft and hydrated so I am definitely
going to keep using this now onto the
glossy Posse volume 5.0 Fenty Beauty
does these gloss sets for the holiday
season every year usually with a limited
edition shade inside this set contains a
gloss bomb cream in cupcake in a gloss
bomb heat and Fenty glow heat and a
regular gloss bomb in fuchsia Flex
cupcaking is a really pigmented gloss
and Fenty glow heat gives you that kind
of spicy tingly lip Plumping fuchsia
Flex is the specific Shade that's been
going viral it's fenty's regular gloss
formula in this really beautiful deep
pink that has a ton of glitter in it all
of these formulas feels so good on the
lips Fenty does not miss with its gloss
formula people have been raving about
the cosas revealer concealer forever so
I finally got it it's supposed to be
medium coverage and super creamy this
concealer was easy to work with and
Blended out so quickly and easily the
coverage looked a bit lighter than
medium to me but it covered enough I
would go in with a little more next time
but I loved how this looked I also got
the cloud set setting powder which
people also really love I used my puff
to apply this and it smoothed everything
out almost instantly I was so impressed
by this powder and I usually hate
pressed powders I never use them let
alone to set my concealer but this
looked so nice I used it on the rest of
my face too and it just gave this really
soft blurred look it mattified but not
too much I loved these two products
especially together this is the
hourglass Cosmetics Phantom volumizing
glossy balm it's supposed to be a lip
balm lip plumper and a lip gloss all in
one product these applied nicely but
because this formula is so fragile it's
easy to apply too much I had to smooth
the product out with my finger a couple
times but other than that I loved these
they have this really nice cooling
effect they do feel like a super
moisturizing lip balm and they have this
High shine finish like a gloss it didn't
do much for me in terms of Plumping so I
think if that's the main thing you want
from a lip product don't get this one I
did a little haul at elf and I got some
new products and some products I've been
wanting to try first up is this elf
luminous putty bronzer this goes from a
putty formula to a powder up close you
can see a lot of Shimmer in this but it
doesn't look that way on the skin this
is one of the most blendable bronzers
I've ever tried like it takes no time at
all to blend this out and it brings a
really natural warmth to the skin this
was so good next I tried the Halo glow
Powder Puff which is always out of stock
people love this I thought it wasn't
going to be any different to my normal
powder Puffs but it is it's much thicker
and softer than these cheap ones I buy
it does pick up a lot of product but I
just evened it out on the back of my
hand this did such a nice job of
applying my powder next I tried the Lash
and roll mascara which kind of reminds
me of the benefit roller lash I usually
hate silicone brush mascaras but I
actually like how this one applied the
product it felt like it got every single
lash my lashes are so straight but this
gave them a nice curl I wish it
thickened my lashes more but for six
bucks this is a really good drugstore
mascara the last product I tested was
the glossy lip stain I can't believe
I've never tried these before this
formula is so interesting it feels like
water on the lips like hydrating but
also weightless these are a bit patchy
there were some areas where it looked
like the product wasn't sticking after
letting the product sit for a few
minutes I removed it and it definitely
did leave a stain behind but the stain
also looked patchy I do like how this
formula feels on the lips but it doesn't
apply evenly for the most part though
this was a pretty good haul
[Music]